[Music]  Scott Disick takes a moment to give  thanks for his kiddos with the sweetest  video ever the 34 year old has had a  tough few years dealing with his ex  Kourtney Kardashian but that doesn't  mean he's lost sight of his three  tiniest blessings this is a serious on  Thursday Scott took to Instagram with  this adorable fatherly moment with  five-year-old Penelope and his youngest  son Raine who really wanted his daddy to  hold him daddy Disney captioned the  precious clip this is why I'm thankful  today  happy Thanksgiving to all meanwhile over  in Cleveland Khloe Kardashian was making  her bow basketball player Tristan  Thompson a very thankful man as well  Coco Coco prepared a Thanksgiving feast  fit for a king  and Thompson documented the entire  spread which included all of the  traditional turkey day fixing plus the  most elaborate dessert bar you've ever  seen the Kardashians definitely know how  to celebrate right  [Music]